hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to another try not to
laugh challenge now this one's going to
be a little different because the
content they're in is from a very
different Source you may know about this
playlist called instant regret clicking
this playlist parentheses memes so these
may be good they may be bad they may be
funny they may be horrifying I honestly
don't know I've never checked out the
playlist so let's see
if any of these
laugh also we are still coming to
Australia and Amsterdam again if you
haven't gotten a ticket yet go to
tour.markiplier.com or check out the
link in the description below to see if
we're coming to a city near you I'm
ready my loins have been girded which is
a phrase that I'm pretty sure applies to
this situation foreign
why won't he open the door
why why won't he open the door what do
you got there you got scissors
give me those scissors no don't run with
sis
the animal ones are always the ones that
almost get me but not this time not this
time not this time
foreign
nope nope
[Music]
I don't know what the hell I'm watching
but it's awesome oh God
are you guys seeing this too
foreign
[Music]
none of those none of those are funny
those are illegal
do you like your new toy
foreign
all right
[Music]
[Music]
we got bagels wow
what the hell was that that's me hit me
hit me hit me you can't reach me with
that hand
reach me with that hand reach me with
that you cannot
reach me with that hand reach me with
that you cannot
[Music]
foreign
not funny loud noises and explosions not
funny
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one
more
Wow since Pilots couldn't see out of the
plane because of angled Landing
Engineers put together a solution and
the Concord featured a droop Snoop droop
snoot no the Snoop would droop the snoot
droop
that's not funny the Concord featured a
droop Snoop droop snoot yeah the Snoop
would droop the snoot droop
that's not funny
there's no nothing funny about do snoot
droop snoot has nothing funny about
droops new group Snoop there's nothing
funny about droop snoot the Snoop
there's nothing funny about droops new
The snoo Troop oh my God that reminds me
of like um a listener to the dollop this
is episode 3 23.
um it's about the race to Paris from New
York done in 1908 is one of the funniest
things I've ever listened to I recommend
listening to it I'll provide a link in
the description to it but this part in
particular is so damn funny and I don't
know why oh he ate a two inch thick
steak while people stood around and
watched and asked him questions this
bogs down into a freak Show
yeah
when not racing you're just kind of road
tripping so why not eat a great is
Robert's the driver of the flyer for the
reporter oh he's the he's the like good
looking athletic dude yeah watch me eat
his steak and I'll make this fat
reporter salivate over it yeah
I wish I could get out of the car
might and tie the grizzle
shut up ham Hawk slap
oh
the uh
Mike didn't I
I'm sorry I have no idea why that's so
funny to get the full context of it I
recommend listening to the episodes It's
so unbelievably funny I'll get back to
the other videos you probably say it a
million times a day
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
who are you I'm Ashley oh [ __ ]
um
totally fine super duper extremo Bonanza
fast any more adjectives or
floating
um not funny
what
like water
all right
why is someone getting hit in the face
so funny
it's not it's mean it hurts oh
Carl
music
wait nah
yip
better Luke the bag says it makes three
dozen cookies why did you make four
[Music]
not funny
I did not hit her it's not true it's
[ __ ]
I knew what was coming I knew it I knew
it was coming I didn't expect it to be
such an elegant pass I'm at 7-Eleven
getting gas right let me insert my card
release card
one moment boneless chicken
is that our car rolling up
can I get acquiescence
[Music]
do you like the snow
why not
can you say snow
[Music]
so my mom tried to be cute
make these little Thanksgiving snacks
here she saw on uh Pinterest this is
what they actually came out with
it's fine what is he doing he's
beginning to believe
foreign
totally fine he discovered Jesus and
then he started doing things and he made
a hot air balloon you know he had a
passion that's Sandhill that way he
wanted you know he had a passion and
this is so beautiful 28 years of
dedication tried dedicating 28 minutes
or something nowadays realistically I
think about that and so I volunteered
more and then eventually they had me be
like a greeter and I would then I was
like well well I agree oh yeah go ahead
next thing you know I'm a caretaker and
I've been living here a year and a half
oh oh
ah that was not funny
ah not funny maybe car dampers is
tougher than you think
we're not gonna win this today
and sing along with me
[Music]
United States this is America
[Music]
no more bouncing that balls
[Music]
what the hell is wrong with you
foreign
that is a cute ass bird
[Music]
s
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's down there somewhere let me take
another look
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
where's the [ __ ] money [ __ ] it's
down there somewhere let me take another
look
[Laughter]
uh
[ __ ] so the playlist is good the
playlist is good but there's a lot of
like repeat offenders in that so there's
a reason why I skipped so many is
because a lot of the times it'll be like
50 videos in a row that are all about
the same exact Meme and it's kind of
like going through memes of history in a
way because you know what was the most
trending topic of that moment because
everybody made a video joking about that
one topic
Chris is not that bad anyway so thank
you everybody so much for watching I
lost as is usual but then again I tried
to go until I lose no matter what
happens so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below and
yes I'm going to Australia in Amsterdam
if you haven't gotten tickets yet check
out tour.markabler.com for
two if you like this let me know in the
comments below and subscribe for more
cool videos like so thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video